mein Aufreger des Tages ist heute das
Buch das Ende des Kapitalismus von der
grünen touchjournalistin Ulrike Herrmann
die hat ihre Parteimitgliedschaft bei
den Grünen übrigens gerade ruhen
gelassen damit ja keine Probleme
aufkommen sie haben Sie vermutlich schon
mal bei Markus Lanz Anne Will oder
Sandra Maischberger im Fernsehen gesehen
lassen wir dir Sie doch einmal selbst
erklären warum sie den Kapitalismus
abschaffen will
aus meiner Sicht ist es so dass
Klimaschutz bedeutet dass man sich vom
Kapitalismus verabschieden muss eine
staatlich gelenkte Privatwirtschaft wo
man sich entscheidet was in dieser
kleinen Kreislaufwirtschaft noch
produziert wird plus Rationierung
das ist unsere Zukunft Herr fahnhold die
Frage würde ich direkt gerne mal an sie
geben hat Frau Herrmann denn Recht das
Kapitalismus und Klimaschutz nicht
zusammen funktioniert nein ganz und gar
nicht recht weil wir brauchen
unternehmerische Initiativen um die
Probleme der Zukunft zu bewältigen wir
sehen ja vor welchen Problemen wir
stehen und dadurch dass man nur abstellt
aussteigt löst man die Probleme nicht
das hat ja nun gerade die Entscheidung
von Minister Habeck gezeigt dass mit
Abstellen von Kernkraftwerken wir mit
Sicherheit die Probleme die vor uns
stehen nicht lösen können
ist sie ein Einzelfall oder merkt man in
Krisenzeiten dass ich Menschen nach
neuen Systemen ja erträumen oder die
sich erwünschten und gegen den
Kapitalismus sind ich bin ja auch
überrascht Frau Hermann hat nämlich mal
ein Buch geschrieben dass hieß kein
Kapitalismus ist auch keine Lösung das
fand ich super genau das stimmt wir
müssen einen soziales
Zusammenleben haben aber es hat sich
ganz gut bewährt soziale Marktwirtschaft
zu haben das ist die bessere Lösung im
Vergleich zu was wollen wir denn haben
Kommunismus oder was soll das sein Frau
Hermann ist auch nicht komplett gegen
den Kapitalismus also man darf ihr Buch
auch wirklich so verstehen dass sie da
den Kapitalismus und den Klimaschutz
zusammen verwebt und sagt im Fall des
Klimaschutzes ist es nicht möglich mit
dem Kapitalismus
großartig also die der der Klimaschutz
das ist etwas was uns allen
Herzen liegt und damit wird jetzt aber
alles mögliche begründet was auf einmal
so rigoros von oben runterkommt und so
ein bisschen knebelt und knechtet ob wir
das wollen ich bezweifle es die größten
co2-missionen stammen aus der Zeit der
DDR das war der größte Umweltsünder der
Welt insofern glaube ich muss sie noch
ein bisschen dazu lernen dass sie zu
solchen schlussfolgen kommen ich glaube
so eine Diskussion
in letzter Konsequenz darf es gar keine
Autos mehr geben das ist das was uns
Grüne natürlich immer einreden wollen
das ist natürlich am Ende schön dass das
mal einer so ausspricht weil wir stellen
ja doch fest dass das Abstellen von
Kraftwerken in Deutschland dazu geführt
hat dass wir jetzt rein Weise
Industriebetriebe abstellen müssen
die Stadtwerke Bremen sind dabei
einzustellen die Hamburger Stahlwerke
also die Stahlwerke Bremen die
Stahlwerke Hamburg die Aluminiumwerke
Neuss die düngemittelfabriken machen zu
und das ist ein Ergebnis der
Energiepolitik der letzten zehn Jahre
die die Grünen immer gerne gewollt haben
mehr sozusagen abstellen und keine Autos
mehr fahren kann Industrie mehr fahren
aber das heißt am Ende den Wohlstand in
Deutschland zerstören und wir sind gut
dabei
abstellen sind wir super und ich sage
noch mal es muss jetzt ein Ende haben
mit der abstellerei und denn wir stehen
vor einer dramatischen
Energiepreisentwicklung kommen wir
gleich noch in der Sendung aber wir
haben mich auch ein Vertreter der FDP
sitzen ein FDP-Politiker und die FDP die
findet die Grünen ja anscheinend gar
nicht so schlimm muss man ja sagen da
gibt es ja gerade die Ampel wie sehen
Sie das denn so die Vorstellung der
Grünen Frau Herrmann ist nur
Parteimitglied was gerade auch gut sie
ist keine Politikerin sondern
Journalistin hier mal die starke
Trennung aber man sieht ja auch bei den
Grünen bei dem ein oder anderen die
Tendenz hin zur grünen Planwirtschaft ja
wir sind in einer gemeinsamen Koalition
aber wir sind schon noch drei
eigenständige Parteien und haben auch
eine eigene Meinung und ich finde
ehrlicherweise das Bild was Frau Hamann
zeichnet ist genauso düster wie der
Hintergrund in dem Ausschnitt den wir
gerade gesehen haben ich höre nur
Verzicht wir fallen zurück in das Jahr
1900 irgendwas ich frag mich wen
vorhermann mit dieser These eigentlich
begeistern will und noch viel schlimmer
finde ich ehrlicherweise sie saß ja in
der Sendung nicht allein sondern neben
Markus Lanz saß unter anderem auch noch
Frank Thelen
Vortrag sie hat vor wenigen Tagen quasi
bei Markus Lanz und Frank
Unternehmer ist Risiken eingeht versucht
die Gesellschaft auch voranzubringen
durch Innovation und dieser Person alles
abzusprechen wofür er wofür er steht
Respekt
nicht darüber zu äußern dass er ja auch
schon mal pleite gegangen ist ich glaube
das ist eine Kommunikation die steht
hier auch nicht an
abzuschweifen der kommt übrigens bald
auch in die Sendung dann werde ich ihn
darauf ansprechen aber um noch einmal
bei Ulrike Herrmann zu bleiben kann man
nicht auch sagen sie spricht es
wenigstens an oder erkennen sie bei
Robert Habeck und den der Grünen
Parteispitze wirklich gar keine
sozialistischen Ansätze naja die Grünen
sind ja im Kern immer noch eine geteilte
Partei aus meiner
Wahrnehmung dass wir kommen ja nachher
noch zum Thema
Atomkraftwerke an die damals einstes
gründeten so ist das so ist das auch in
der Diskussion jetzt bei den
Atomkraftwerken ist das ja eine
Diskussion zwischen zwei grünen Ressorts
mit Robert Halberg und der Frau Lemke
die sich in der Frage ja auch nicht
einig sind insofern das sind Fragen der
Grünen die sie untereinander klären
müssen wie sie auch zu Frau Hermann
steht bei der FDP wird man damit nicht
durchdringen wir haben eine andere
Vorstellung von der Zukunft und wollen
nicht zurück in die Vergangenheit aber
mit den Grünen ins Bett legen für die
Macht machen sie schon
nee wir tragen staatspolitische
Verantwortung und sind in diese
Koalition eingestiegen und es ist schon
so wie Jamaika damals haben sie gesagt
lieber nicht regieren als falschregieren
da warst mit der Verantwortung nicht so
weit hergeholt ja
Jamaika stand ja beim letzten Mal wieder
zur Debatte das ist allerdings an der
CSU und an Markus Söder gescheitert weil
er sich beste Mühe gegeben hat also
Jamaika zu verunmöglichen und ich glaube
die CDU hat sich bis heute noch nicht
von den Folgen dieser internen
Machtkämpfe erholt aber in der Tat wir
regieren mit zwei linken Parteien das
hat sich ein bisschen was geändert weil
wir als FTP versuchen das Land in der
Mitte zu halten und wir sind der festen
Überzeugung dass das besser ist als von
außen zuzuschauen wie das dann nach
links geht also jetzt wieder eigentlich
die Regelung Hauptsache regieren egal
nicht wir sind für Trendwenden
angetreten und wir können auch einiges
durchsetzen wenn wir uns jetzt mal das
Entlastungspaket anschauen oder die drei
entlastungspakete die es gab die jetzt
ohne fdp-beteiligung sicherlich nicht so
einfach
die entl Pakete sieht und generell wie
zufriedene Akteur mit der Arbeit der
Ampel ist
die letzte Frage will ich gar nicht so
beantworten weil ich glaube dass unserem
Land gerade ein bisschen Führung fehlt
und das was der Bürger das ganz schön
widerspiegelt ein drei Entlastungspaket
das heißt zweimal hat man es falsch
gemacht und jetzt kommt das dritte wir
geben 100 Milliarden Euro aus und die
Frage ist letztendlich für den Menschen
der es braucht was kommt überhaupt bei
mir an wir haben 12 Euro Mindestlohn den
braucht man auch dringend weil sonst
kann man nicht mehr über die Runden weil
die steigenden Lebensmittelpreisen dann
wird das Kindergeld erhöht wovon der
Hartz IV oder transferleistende gar
nichts von abbekommt weil es wird die
wieder von seinen Regeln setzen
abgezogen und jetzt kommt er jetzt das
Bürgergeld das Bürgergeld kommt ja mal
gucken wie weit die Kosten dann noch
steigen die Frage ist letztendlich
wieder normale Bürger die Mittelschicht
bricht immer mehr weg wir merken das als
Arche wir haben immer weniger Spender
aus diesem Bereich wir haben alleine in
diesem Jahr 1500 Spender verloren die
uns schreiben wir können uns uns nicht
mehr leisten 20 oder 50 Euro euch zu
spenden weil wir haben zu wenig Geld in
der Tasche die Lebensmittelpreise
steigen bis ins Unermessliche und
teilweise bis zu 100% und nicht nur 7,5
irgendwas bei uns versucht auch ein
bisschen vorzugaukeln finde ich und wir
haben viele Familien gerade
alleinerziehende Mütter die nicht mehr
klarkommen die haben Angst vor
Obdachlosigkeit und diese Bürger und das
werden immer mehr die finden kaum noch
Hilfe weil die Tafeln haben keine
Lebensmittel mehr die haben immer mehr
Menschen aus der Ukraine die haben
deutsche die haben Familien die nicht
mehr über die Runden kommen die nehmen
gar keine neuen mehr auf und wer heute
unverschuldet in armutgerät der hat kaum
noch eine Chance überhaupt an
Lebensmittel zu kommen sondern die Frage
ist ob die Bundesregierung wirklich
verstanden hat was ist das Problem
dieser Zeit wenn immer mehr Menschen in
Armut geraten dann muss man auch immer
mehr tun aber nicht 65 Milliarden Euro
rausholen und alle Menschen beschenken
sage ich mal auch diejenigen die es gar
nicht